on the 6th of july the official eldon
ring website
updated with a new description it reads
as follows
the golden order has been shattered
throughout the lands between
demigods holding shards of the olden
ring squabble
and make war over the ruins of a perfect
realm
now abandoned by the golden guidance of
the greater will
as the echoes of this cotton flicked
thunder in the distance
an outcast arrives once their ancestors
called the lands between
home but the blessed light of grace was
lost to their tribe long ago
and they were expelled from the kingdom
they are the tarnished and they have
returned to claim the elden lordship
promised to them by legend those few
inhabitants who are not mad or hostile
linger near the broken remnants of
cities left behind by the shattering
they may have answers for you if you
help them above them all
ensconced in legacies bristling with
traps secrets
and guardians the demigods walk to lords
who began as members of a royal and
noble family rule their domains with the
unyielding power granted by shards
of the elden ring this is probably all
the story we're going to get
until gamescom at the end of august and
combined with everything else it's
actually a ton to go over
so i've shattered it all into eight
sections
let's get into it starting with the
character that they seem to be building
up
as the main antagonist of elden ring her
name
is queen marika the eternal she's first
mentioned on the official site which
reads
in the lands between ruled by queen
marika the eternal
the olden ring the source of the earth
tree has been shattered
marika's offspring demigodzol claimed
the shards of the olden ring known as
the great runes
and the mad taint of their newfound
strength
triggered a war so the japanese word
that they use for eternal
is actually the same one they used to
describe
the perpetuity of the everlasting
dragons in dark souls
so she likely has a sort of immortality
akin to them her offspring are demigods
after all so it would make some sense
that she is
a sort of deity now it still is possible
that marika
is innocent in all of this and that her
offspring alone
are responsible for the shattering that
said a russian
site calls her the mistress of the
coveted ring
which i think suggests she has claimed
at least some
of its power and assuming that she's
still the ruler of the lands between
it is at least being implied that she
has benefited from
and played a part in the ring's
shattering
so from what i can tell so far the
reasons for shattering the ring
might be a to claim its power but also
b to upset the world order and sort of
inspire chaos
because despite marika quote unquote
ruling the lands between her demigod
offspring
are actually squabbling with one another
and they're making war
it doesn't exactly show that she's got
control of them or that she even wants
to stop them making war
it seems like each demigod has a chunk
of the open world under their dominion
almost like a country
according to an interview with miyazaki
each demigod can be found at
the end of legacy dungeons and since
there is one
legacy dungeon per open world that means
yeah each demigod likely has a chunk of
this open world
to themselves this sort of drama between
kingdoms
is exactly what you'd expect from george
r martin's writing
and since we're expected to delve into
the complex
bloody history of the shattering i
expect there to be a ton of law
behind each demigod and kingdom a large
part of the designs of these major
characters will be
how they were twisted by claiming shards
of the olden ring
according to miyazaki they each
inherited a different
power or element so to speak and each
was twisted and warped in its own way
and it brought a tainted strength to
each of them they each fell to madness
and fell to ruin in their own individual
ways
so while there is heroic and
mythological elements to them
they are also going to have this very
mad taint and this
deep-seated ruin and it seems like one
such lord has already been revealed to
us
this heavily armed boss is referenced in
a tweet from june 24th
which reads a lord clings to his ruined
legacy
the ruler of a husk rung dry by war
and while i guess it's possible that
he's a lord from the world before
the shattering clinging to his ruined
legacy
it's still more likely to me that he's a
demigod since he's a perfect example of
a character that
looks tainted and ruined by the olden
ring and you have to wonder
did any of them including marika expect
the alden ring to
twist and taint them in such a way do
they even care
according to the official site the
shards of the elden ring
are called great runes so runes are
simply a type of
nordic alphabet but in fantasy writing
they're often used as
words of magical power together it seems
these runes spell the elden ring but
since the olden ring has been
shattered alone some of these runes have
been
claimed a long long time ago the
earliest leak about
eldon ring actually revealed the game
was once called great rune
and it was said to be a game about
travelling to distant kingdoms
and claiming the power that lies there
therefore
i wonder if defeating a demigod might
allow you to
claim their power or their rune in some
way
perhaps getting a specific ability or
type of power up
according to the trailer the elden ring
is a weapon after all
listen brandish the elden ring
for all of us they're doing such a good
job with the concept of the olden ring
because
even though we kind of know so much
about it it's still hard to pin down
exactly what it is it's made up of runes
which makes it
literal it gives order to the world
making it seem
conceptual and yet it's also physical
it's able to be hammered and shattered
into pieces
actually one really awesome discovery i
saw recently
was how similar the shattering scene
with the blacksmith
is to this forging the ring concept art
by alan lee who has done a ton of
official artwork for tolkien's
lord of the rings series i believe this
is sauron forging the one ring
and like the one ring the elden ring
also has text upon it
it's also a weapon of great power
and perhaps most importantly it also has
a will associated with it according to
the official site
when the demigods triggered the
shattering war they were abandoned
by the greater will now somehow this
greater will
persists despite the ring being
shattered and
has decided that these demigods who were
once members of a royal and
noble family are no longer worthy of its
favor
instead it seems this favor has been
returned
to us instead the tarnished
according to miyazaki you could call
them tarnished individuals who have lost
grace and this was a long time preceding
the setting of the game
a long time before the ancestors of the
characters that are present in the world
were banished and exiled from the lands
between
these tarnished then a long time after
that the olden ring was shattered in a
historical event
this triggers the return of this lost
grace and it calls out to the tarnished
who were once exiled from the lands
between and it guides them back
so this is the starting point or the
impetus for the game itself
the tarnished being called by the lost
grace and returning to the lands between
the tarnished sound a lot like the
unkindled from dark souls 3
in the sense that they were also deemed
unworthy a long time ago
but now are being called back almost as
a last resort
it's a chance to redeem ourselves but
don't you guys also think that it kind
of feels
a bit insulting like oh now you need us
you know miyazaki does go on to say i
feel like one of the main themes of the
game is how the player the tarnished
approaches or treats this newfound grace
and this
return to the land that they were once
banished from
how they interpret this and the meaning
it's not just the player character of
course it's lots of characters in the
game who are all
beckoned back and will have their own
adventures and motives
we want the player to discover for
themselves what that means and
how they want to begin their adventure
in dark souls 3
we stood before the soul of cinder
itself and we had the choice to take its
place and
restore the current world order as
unkindled ash this
is kind of our logical goal but after
you see what happened to all the other
lords of cinder you
are supposed to realize that being a
lord of cinder is a very
sacrificial subservient role similarly
the goal for our tarnished is to stand
before the elden ring
and become a quote elden lord
and you know while that sounds like a
real power fantasy title
i'm sure in reality it won't be as great
as it sounds
the shards of the elden ring have
twisted the demigods
after all and imagine what its full
power
might do to us a tarnished and the word
tarnished is just such a wonderful term
for these characters because when a
metal is tarnished it means it's lost
its luster
similarly we've lost our golden grace
and
specifically this golden grace was once
found in our eyes
miyazaki says the lands between are
blessed by the presence of the olden
ring
and by the odd tree which symbolizes its
presence and this has given grace or
blessing to the people throughout the
land
great and small what this represents in
them is a sort of golden light or a
golden aura
that is specifically shown in their eyes
and this symbolizes the blessing or the
grace of the old tree
however after a time there were some
individuals who lost this grace
and the light faded from their eyes and
these
are what are known as the tarnished also
if this boss is indeed a demigod then
unsurprisingly you know he no longer has
golden eyes interesting then that he
speaks down to us
it's like man i don't see any golden
grace in your eyes either so whatever
sin
the tarnished committed ages ago must
set us apart
and even though we've apparently
regained some of that grace
our golden light doesn't seem to have
returned to our eyes
either so all we've been able to do is
just return to the lands between
for now to get to the lands between you
apparently have to traverse
the foggy sea since we know the lands
between are an open world and that's
where most of the game takes place
i bet traversing this sea of fog is a
sort of tutorial level
developers have to control your
experience at the start of the game
right they have to
teach you the ropes like the journey to
the nexus in demon souls or
escaping from the asylum in dark souls
and once you've made it through this
section
you're on your own and you're free to go
and die in the catacombs
so to speak the lands between or the
rift lands as they've been called
are the ruins of a perfect realm now
ruled by queen marika
remember the things betwixt area at the
start of dark souls 2
it uses the same japanese word that
roughly translates to
interspace in its name and so does the
lands between
so maybe these two places are comparable
in some way
the question is the lands between what
above obviously
is the higher plane marked by the light
beyond the earth tree
but then what is below earth hell
we are considered dead beings after all
maybe that's where we come from
alternatively there are a lot of spirits
in the lands between
like our horse so maybe the lands
between are a world where
creatures have one foot in the mortal
realm and one in the divine
it's hard to say for sure at any rate
the lands between
are really intertwined and they appear
to be actually like
layered on top of one another around the
earth tree
proof of this is seen in this snowy
world where we are
significantly closer to the top of the
tree than in the other scenes where
you could even see the higher planes in
the distance according to this tweet
from june 15th
our path reaches up to the branches of
the heavens
and twists down to the roots of the
earth
i love the order to all of these
concepts you know starting at the top
there is the greater will which sounds
akin to a god
capable of being incredibly benevolent
blessing
land and also incredibly vindictive
exiling those who displease it
it's probably responsible for the golden
order of the world
the japanese word for which translates
to commandment
or law and then for lack of a better
word the greater will is
aligned with the elden ring as it has
clearly taken offence to its shattering
the elden ring is at the heart of the
earth tree and
the pure light beyond the earth tree
filters down through its branches and is
called the guidance of grace or the
grace of gold
this gold manifests upon the lands
between as pockets of lost grace which
act as checkpoints to guide the player
and
this grace manifests within characters
as golden
eyes see what i mean there's a lot there
now originally i thought our character
was marked as a tarnished by their gray
hair
but in my comment section bandai namco
actually clarified that
in the lands between a tarnished is not
marked by the loss of the colour red
but of another colour now we know that
colour is gold but the question remains
who are the red-haired race of beings
namely this giant and this valkyrie the
big war we know about
is the shattering war and i bet that
that's what we're witnessing here
because of this scene where a soldier
strikes this giant right at the moment
we're presented with
the ring shattering therefore you'd
think the redhead race would be enemies
of the demigods like we are
so why then does the valkyrie impale us
is the sin our tarnished ancestors
committed ages ago
so terrible that they're hated by
literally everyone
even the enemy of our enemy maybe this
is a random note but in the last video i
thought you could see a bit of red
inside the new fire keeper's hood
however there's been a bit of debate on
the reddit regarding whether it's
actually red
or a trick of the light since it appears
more golden in this scene
it would certainly be interesting if she
was one of the red-haired race
but we'll have to wait and see speaking
of redhead characters
one of my favorite fantasy stories of
all time is
the name of the wind by patrick rothfuss
and it features a protagonist
known for his fiery red hair okay he's
actually known for a bit more than that
let me pull up this excerpt from audible
and i'll let him explain
i have stolen princesses back from
sleeping barrow kings
i burn down the town of trebon
i have spent the night with valorian and
left with both my sanity
and my life i was expelled from the
university at a younger age than most
people are allowed in
i tread paths by moonlight that others
fear to speak of during day
i have talked to gods loved women
and written songs that make the
minstrels weep
you may have heard of me this is an
audiobook you can listen to for free
during your 30-day audible trial so go
and visit audible.com or text
vaatividia to 500-500 to start your free
trial
right now the name of the wind is a
three-part series
and it seems like the third novel might
never come out at this point
but hey that makes it a perfect
recommendation for eldon ring fans right
i know how much you guys love waiting
seriously though the author is actually
fantastic especially at intriguing the
reader with
all sorts of questions about the story
while also
hiding the answers to that story all
throughout the series
it's kind of like what souls does with
it's law
honestly it's one of my favorite stories
of all time
really and i know a lot of people in the
comments can vouch
for the name of the wind being amazing
as well
so again go and visit audible.com
varietyvideo or text
variety video to 500 500 to get started
today
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video and
thank you as always for watching
you